من منحى النحال ميكائيل العراقي احنا لانه
نتحدث اليوم عن موضوع يخص النحل اللي هو
هجوم النحل الجائع كما وصفه المواطنون في
ذي قار خاصه في قضاء الشطره في الجانب
الشرقي من محافظه ذي قار هناك يهاجم النحل
المواطنين والمواطنين يعني رفعوا شكواهم
الى
السلطات الطبيه وطالبوها بالضغط على اصحاب
المنال في ذلك القضاء يعني
اخذ الاحتياطات اللازمه لتقليل هجوم النحل
على المواطنين خاصه يعني الاماكن التي
تتواجد فيها يعني الاشياء السكريه خاصه
العراقيين مشهورين في فصل الصيف بشرب بشرب
الشاي والشايكون مسكر جدا وهذا يتسبب ايضا
بهجوم النحل هناك في ذلك القضاء على
المواطنين طبعا هذه ليست ليست الصيف الاول
يعني
الذي تتعرض له القضاء لهجوم كائنات لكن
مختلفه في الصيفين السابقين كان هناك هجوم
للذئاب وكذلك هجوم للكلاب
العراقيون يعني ناقصين كمان هجوم النحل
وبكفيهم الهموم النفسيه على ما يبدو هناك
موضوع اخر يتحدث عن تاثير الهموم النفسيه
على العراقين
طبعا هو هو هجوم النحل كفيل اصلا يعني
تسبب بيها الشاشه نفسيه طبعا منظمه الصحه
العالميه اعلنت ان واحد بين اربع بين كل
اربع عراقيين يعني مصاب بالهشاشه النفسيه
وهذا ما يعني ان هنالك 18% من العراقيين
مصابين يعني سوء الحاله النفسيه اي ما
يعادل سبع ملايين عراقي والاسباب التي
يعني ذكرها المختصون مختلفه فالحرب
والحصار وما تلاها من ارهاب وحروب طائفيه
كلها كانت كفيله بذلك ايضا الخبراء ذكروا
ان يعني كل شخص يعاني من عرض واحد من
اعراض الكابه او الهشاشه النفسيه على
الاقل مثل الحزن بدون مبرر او الانعزال عن
المجتمع وغيرها من الاسباب نعم يا راويه
يا زينب لربما دائما ما نقول بانه يعني
حتى في الحضارات المتعاقبه في العراق
والدول المتعاقبه في العراق كان الحزن
لربما وفيضان النهر نهر دجله والفرات كان
يسبب تلك الازمات النفسيه شكرا زينب
بالمشاط يعطيك العافيه ديري بالك من النحل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات